I was watching this video Filipino food
oh that looks good it does look good but
it's under appreciated all right you
guys ready for this yeah so this is in
the middle of the documentary so it's
Filipino food they're talking about how
it's the most
hated no oh my God
what it has the
tissue they took us
seriously God they believe my God that
is amazing
that made my whole day we made it it's
going to the Moon I was telling my
father-in-law about this bit about how I
hate Filipino food he was crying he
couldn't even breathe he was laughing so
hard he couldn't even breathe I can't
believe they took it seriously they're
using it as an element to support a
narrative that I didn't even know
existed honestly I didn't know that like
most people hate Philip I think Steve
started the narrative no can we go back
to my outfit how can you take this guy
seriously and then cut to the guy with
the nose bleed